yes after the blitz tournament but i  wasn't sure if it was a good idea in  terms of the armageddon but it worked  well  it did work out nicely do you think we  need more stats and chess like i like  basketball and in the mba you have stats  for everything and you can study forever  well chess okay we have the head-to-head  score  but it's not so easy to have all these  statistics who does well who has what  rating performance with what i mean you  can generate them all but it's not like  they're being debated like in nba or nfl  or anything  yeah and andy is a  team sport but they actually make sense  i'm sure that magnus has statistics  about his opponents  i'm not sure you're not sure  but i haven't seen them  yeah we do have a result uh  did lose in the armageddon game against  maxine russia legrace